[Música]
e
muy buenas tardes a todos ustedes
después de este momento tan emotivo de
las palabras que dirigió hubo
me da mucho gusto con ustedes compartir
en un momento de mi vida lo que les voy
a platicar
corría el año de 1951
cuando mi familia me llevó a ver la
primera edición de la carrera
panamericana
esta pasó por el tramo de ixtlahuaca
atlacomulco
fue tal me impactó
de ese evento
que le pedí en el año de 1952 a los
santos reyes que me trajeran
un carro un carro de pedales que fuera
muy veloz
y mi sueño
se hizo realidad y aquí lo tienen
ustedes con 66 años que me ha acompañado
también
en los festejos
del 16 de septiembre de zinacantepec
se organizó una carrera de carros de
pedales que fuimos seis participantes
lógico todos queríamos tener el triunfo
el evento fue de 80 metros
40 de bajada y 40 de subida
yo no iba liderando
en los primeros 40 metros
pero los gritos
que se apodera mos de mis sentidos
diciéndome chacho como mi familia me
dice y mis amigos tu puedes tú puedes
esos gritos se apoderaron precisamente
de mi mente y con un segundo esfuerzo
llegué a cruzar la meta y no sólo eso el
presidente municipal de turno me otorgó
esta copa que dice al vencedor 1952
el respirar el olor a triunfo
verdaderamente lo contagian
y esta experiencia a la cual me estoy
dirigiendo a todos ustedes dijo
funda huella en mi vida que la quiero
permear a las generaciones futuras
precisamente para que con trabajo
constancia perseverancia honestidad
puntualidad empujemos a este tipo de
generaciones a un logro mayor
en este caminar por la vida
conocí a una persona
que me introdujo
al manejo profesional del fútbol
esta persona incluyente
participativa
justiciero con razón y nunca se guardó
un secreto para manejar el fútbol
profesional
y al lado
p
compartimos dos campeonatos de fútbol
que fue el del 2008 y del 2010
me refiero con esto porque mi hijo
roberto salgado mercado
con responsabilidades diferentes
de mercadotecnia y en lo financiero
deportivo me acompañó en esto por lo
cual el día de hoy en frente de ustedes
testigos de esta plática le quiero
entregar este balón simbólico para que
incremente su experiencia de tipo
profesional y que permite y alargue
precisamente en esta especialidad de lo
que somos padre e hijo gracias
[Aplausos]
mi nombre es roberto salgado mercado
estamos anulados por la experiencia de
la vida por la sangre por el aprendizaje
y por muchas otras cosas y así así es
como tuvimos la fortuna
y el gusto de ganar dos títulos de
campeonato de primera división
profesional aún recuerdo cuando
terminaba el partido y finalmente
podíamos saber en nuestras manos el
pedazo de metal que representaba haber
ganado el campeonato
el esfuerzo había valido la pena aún
recuerdo salir a caminar a la calle y
ver como la gente estaba contagiada de
este sentimiento de esta alegría porque
el campeonato verdaderamente era de
todos
termino finalmente las festividades y
empezar un nuevo torneo con nuevos bríos
nuevos retos pero no siempre se gana
hay finales que se pierden de manera
abrupta uno no espera la derrota
y uno no está preparado para eso
por eso hay que entender que la derrota
es un momento que hay que saber
administrar la derrota
no todo está perdido
es momento de hacer una reflexión
con uno mismo que podemos mejorar cómo
reestructurar cómo podemos ser mejores
en ciertos momentos también reconocerá
el rival
por eso es momento
en esos momentos de crisis
pues más se añora y más se valora el
truco y se extraña
porque se aprende más en la derrota
que en el triunfo
pero el triunfo nos deja marcados nos
marca muy profundo porque todos en la
vida hemos ganado en algo
en un juego de mesa
en una competencia en un partido en algo
y todos hemos experimentado ese
sentimiento de satisfacción de alegría
entonces es por eso que debemos de
rodearnos de esos elementos que nos
vinculan con el triunfo posiblemente
esos olores posiblemente esos sonidos
esa música esos colores esas personas
y es justamente que se agradece a todas
esas personas que hacen evidente los
mensajes de apoyo los mensajes positivos
porque esos mensajes nos llegan y tienen
un efecto sobre nosotros
y un ejemplo de esto es cuando una
persona en el estadio decide organizar
un mensaje de apoyo un grito una porra y
lo logra y al final vemos un estadio al
unísono apoyando a su equipo
eso tiene un efecto
es algo que nos llega que nos mueve
imaginemos también cuando una persona
por iniciativa una sola persona decide
organizar la ola aquella que viéramos en
méxico de 1986
y lo logra logra movilizar todo un
estadio de manera coordinada
y es con la iniciativa de una sola
persona
por eso cada amanecer hay gente que está
enfrentando la competencia de su vida en
el día a día con diferentes objetivos y
los invito a que hagamos evidente
nuestros mensajes de apoyo a toda esa
gente que está en un momento clave un
momento por lograr su meta su objetivo
su triunfo
nosotros podemos hacer la diferencia
hoy tenemos en nuestras manos el
espíritu de ganar por eso debemos de
estar anulados a través del olor a
triunfo muchas gracias